a somber ceremony for a country in this
array
a year after president jovenel moyes was
assassinated haitian authorities and
diplomats met to mark the occasion
current acting president ariel henry
says he's committed to seeking justice
i'm determined to encourage the
continuation of the investigation until
its conclusion haitian justice can count
on the unconditional support of the
government despite its weaknesses the
justice system must continue to track
down and sentence the culprits so that
our country will never have to go
through such drama again
but despite dozens of arrests including
a group of colombian mercenaries haiti's
investigation remained stalled and many
accuse henry himself of being involved
after he fired his justice minister and
a prosecutor last year when they called
for him to be investigated in connection
with the murder
he denies any involvement
on thursday hundreds took to the streets
of the capital porto prince in protest
burning tires and calling for henry's
resignation the prime minister must go
to jail because he was involved in the
killing of the president this is not
normal in the 21st century it is
shocking but his legacy will not die we
will continue
[Music]
some of the arrested colombian
mercenaries have released a video saying
they had gone over 70 hours without food
they haven't been charged and haven't
had access to a lawyer for 10 months
a separate investigation in the u.s has
led to three arrests including a former
u.s government criminal informant
in a statement on thursday u.s secretary
of state anthony blinken said the u.s
remains concerned about the limited
progress of haiti's investigation
since the killing the already fragile
economic and political situation in the
country fell deeper into this function
as gangs took over large parts of the
capital
thousands of people have been killed
tortured or forced to leave
well what has happened in haiti for the
past years shows that shortcuts do not
work there is a crisis it's getting
worse so we need to tackle the issues we
need to make sure that we fight gang
violence and have a political consensus
and have free election
but when none of these options on the
horizon haitians are left in a grim
spiral of violence and impunity that
sees an ever growing number of them
ready to risk their life to leave the
country alessandro
al-jazeera